[Music]
there are two moments in Planet of Lana
that made me realize I was playing
something special
the first was literally a big moment the
camera pulled back in an unfathomably
large creature swam under my boat its
bodies seemed to keep going and going
and there was a sense I'd surely be
capsized and eaten but instead it simply
passed on leaving me with an
overwhelming feeling that I wasn't the
center of this world
the second moment was small I misjudged
a jump and a predator caught me okay
time to try again after respawning I
decided to outrun the enemy since that's
usually something you can do in video
games I didn't even get close
it's rare that a game makes you feel
truly unimportant like you're just a
tiny part of a much larger environment
when a title successfully instills this
feeling it can be like witnessing a sort
of magic trick so what I'd like to do
today is take you backstage and explore
how different games succeed in making
you part of their ecosystems
okay so how do you get past a predator
and planet of Lana the answer is you
have to move slowly learning the root of
an enemy be they biological or
mechanical and finding a way to evade
them altogether from very early on this
title establishes that you're much too
insignificant to overcome dangers
directly instead planet of Lana is a
game all about understanding the
ecosystem knowing how different threats
operate and putting that knowledge into
practice to escape creatures much higher
up the food chain than you are the
character you play as is not
particularly skillful your fastest
running speed is a leisurely jog your
jump is barely enough to cross most gaps
you fall and stumble down Cliff's most
video game characters wouldn't even be
remotely bothered by and unfortunately
the land itself feels hostile eyes peer
out from the darkness of most
environments and with no health bar
you're always one wrong move away from
game over but if you pay attention you
realize the game is constantly teaching
you about how its ecosystem works early
in Planet of Lana there's a part where a
tiny creature scuttles under a rock as
you wander by later you pass a giant
rock and it Lumbers after you on
hundreds of tiny feet the game is full
of these little moments of internal
consistency and once you learn the rules
of how the environment functions the
path forward becomes clear
but what about a game where you
experience an ecosystem not as a human
but is something a bit smaller
introducing webbed a physics-based
platformer where you play as a peacock
spider moving around and webbed is quite
difficult at least for me I found my
first attempts at traversal wildly messy
instead of gracefully swinging on webs
my spider careened around at high speeds
crashing repeatedly into the foliage my
initial attempt at spinning a
fly-catching web was equally sad
yielding a crummy asymmetrical disaster
that was utterly ineffective and this
was a real problem because in the
virtual ecosystem of webbed nearly every
insect is larger than you are and the
ultimate goal of the game is to rescue
your mate from a relatively Titanic
Bower bird a task that seemed downright
impossible at the start but to succeed
in the environment of webbed you can't
think like a human you have to to think
like a spider once I got used to having
a body light as air I began to swing
around with much greater success with
practice I even managed to pull off some
rather fancy movement techniques my fly
catching webs also improved at first my
few meager strands only ensnared a meal
on rare occasions but the more I crafted
wider networks closer in design to those
of real world spiders the more I found
my food came to me one of the most
impressive aspects of webbed is how game
mechanics come together with its virtual
ecosystem to make you inhabit a
perspective you otherwise might never
consider granted webbed is not trying to
perfectly simulate the experience of
being a spider spiders generally can't
fire off a never-ending barrage of webs
like their Spider-Man they also can't do
sick tricks on a skateboard which is
something you can eventually unlock but
the core gameplay truly does excel at
making you feel like you're part of an
ecosystem
another game that can successfully
hijack your mind is given beyond the
trees in this game you live the
fast-paced high-stakes life of a gibbon
swinging Full Tilt through the
rainforest canopy like and webbed your
method of traversal is unintuitive at
first but with practice it starts to
feel unbelievably natural with every
movement a glorious expression of
momentum there's a certain feeling you
get when you perfectly sync up with your
fellow ape releasing at just the right
moment for an incredible Rush of speed
it feels astonishingly good to grab a
Vine and hold it for a long swing
letting go at the very top and gaining
tremendous height though the ecosystem
itself is less interactive than some of
the others in this video it's still
deeply immersive with other animals
finding their own path through the
branches and the weather changing at
unexpected times given sense of
spontaneity is bolstered by the game's
use of procedural animation or animation
that responds dynamically to an
environment instead of following a
predetermined loop it's the same
animation method that makes the
creatures of rain World feel so
unpredictable since I've already covered
rain world and detail Elsewhere on the
channel I won't say too much about it
simulated ecosystem but it's another
example of a game that can be so
mechanically immersive it changes your
perspective as you play it making you
think and react like a prey animal
living in an environment that isn't
centered around you Gibbon similarly has
these moments that convey your
characters utter insignificance there
are places where the camera zooms all
the way out to capture an incredible
leap across an immense Chasm part of
what makes these moments so breathtaking
is the knowledge that you aren't
watching some predetermined animation if
you make a single mistake you will
absolutely fall if you stop thinking
with your Gibbon brain and miss a branch
you'll come crashing to the force below
which isn't such a big deal if you're
close to the ground but definitely is in
the high canopy the effect is a world
that is not only expansive but
indifferent to the player in a way that
makes the environment feel all the
vaster
planet of Lana has its own share of zoom
out moments that let you soak in the
sheer scale of the world around you but
unlike in Gibbon it's not just the
environments that are massive but the
entities that inhabit them amidst the
graveyard of giant fractured skeletons
you can find in the Gloom of a cave the
many glowing eyes of a monstrous
spider-like entity who Towers over you
to such an extent it seems unfair some
mechanical entities stand even taller
and while for much of the game the
largest units appear only in the
background there are some sequences
where you get up close with these
machines that are just spellbinding
rarely have I felt less significant to A
Game's world than I did during these
sections but the most stupefying
expression of scale and planet of Lana
doesn't involve robots or giant monsters
instead it's a relatively quiet moment
where your character runs through an
empty expanse with their animal
companion the the camera starts pulling
back revealing the Stars overhead you
watch as your character appears to grow
smaller and smaller and you think surely
the perspective can't get any wider but
the zoom out just keeps going you become
nothing but a tiny dot in the corner of
the screen and still the frame isn't
done expanding as the Sun starts to peek
Over the Horizon I timed it and it takes
almost three real world minutes for the
sequence to conclude but I absolutely
could not have told you this number
while playing because while I watched
the sun rise over the distant mountains
time just sort of lost all meaning the
rest of the world faded away leaving
only myself in the infinite vastness of
the cosmos above
though there are other parts of planet
of Lana that are technically more
bombastic and cinematic it's this
section that made me truly feel like a
small part of something much greater
I've gotten a similar feeling of
smallness while playing open World Games
sometimes due to the density of their
worlds and sometimes due to the sheer
scope many modern titles can instill a
sense of insignificance Simply from how
long it takes to cross their map but
where most open World Games differ from
the Indie titles mentioned so far is
that while the player is typically a
minute part of the environment they can
often change the ecosystem around them
to a more significant degree this can
cause players to feel above an ecosystem
rather than part of it but it can also
pull them in deeper in one open world in
particular I found myself immersed in
was Hyrule from The Legend of Zelda
breath of the wild the land of Hyrule
isn't just varied or simply big but also
a world that requires you to understand
and interact with its systems to
progress as you play you learn to chop
down trees to cross gaps and to cook
meals you find ways to overcome freezing
cold of the tundra in the blistering
heat of the desert a lot of people have
already talked about how immersive this
world feels and I certainly agree but I
think I felt even closer to the world
when I played tears of the Kingdom a
direct sequel to breath of the wild
tears of the Kingdom takes you back to
the same Hyrule and yet I found myself
more immersed in the cell-shaded
environments than I ever had been in the
game's predecessor a big reason for this
difference is fuse a super bizarre new
mechanic that lets you merge practically
anything in the environment with
whatever is in your hand it's an ability
that made me think more about the world
around me without even realizing it
because most objects in the world now
had a special utility that only fuse
could bring out I found myself engaging
more with the virtual ecosystem around
me I explored each section of the world
more thoroughly I started to know
different types of berries by side alone
I learned more about all the different
Elemental interactions the game's
physics system makes possible the simple
Act of experimenting with different
in-game systems became one of my
favorite activities I also found myself
seeking out different enemy types just
to discover what sort of fuse materials
I could obtain my curiosity was further
encouraged by the greater variety of
creatures and tears of the Kingdom which
exhibit a wider array of emergent
behaviors that makes the ecosystem feel
more unpredictable I felt like the game
was rewarding me for learning how its
World functioned pushing me to discover
all its hidden Networks
there's another block here open world
game that rewards you for intimate
knowledge of its ecosystem like Zelda
Minecraft balances huge lonely
environments with deep systems of
learnable interactivity while much of
Minecraft has to do with mining it's
also very much a game about knowing what
plants are edible what types of animals
respond positively to what types of
crops what can be turned into your Ally
and what sees you as food it might not
immediately strike you as a game that
makes you part of its ecosystem but
personally when I'm in the early stages
of a playthrough and I hear the
vocalizations of giant spiders my brain
is still conditioned to go on alert like
a prey animal knowing things about the
world like don't get too close to the
weird green guy or don't look the lanky
fellow directly in the eyes are
absolutely key to survival Minecraft
also puts emphasis on different biomes
encouraging the player to learn what can
be found in which type of environment as
they navigate a nearer infinite
landscape
tears of the Kingdom similarly
incentivizes knowledge of different
environments retaining nudges the
different biomes present in breath of
the wild but adding two all-new
ecosystems that feel radically different
from one another the game is essentially
three worlds stacked on top of each
other the bright sunny islands in the
sky the vast and varied surface world
and the dark and Eerie depths below even
more than different Minecraft biomes all
of these ecosystems have their own rules
and their own Aesthetics that reinforce
those rules the depths are meant to be
this hostile lost realm of foreboding
flora and fauna which is why I thought
it was clever that the plants here seem
to take inspiration from prehistoric
species even the insects down here look
more like something from the Cambrian
era and what you find in each realm
encourages you to explore the others the
sundelion flowers of the sky islands
give you resistance to the depths
likewise the bright Bloom seeds you find
in caves in the sky and on the surface
are absolutely critical for lighting
your way when you explore the dark
underground and while exploring the
depths you'll find powerful fuse
materials that make you feel more
equipped to take on challenges in the
other two realms
Minecraft has its own parallel realm in
the nether a fiery Dimension filled with
creatures and biomes completely
different from the Overworld as is the
case in Zelda if you weren't careful the
different rules of this domain can catch
you off guard and lead to disaster
there are other open world games that
succeed in making you feel like the
underdog Horizon zero Dawn with its
artificial ecosystem of towering
machines and subnautica with its
thalassophobia-inducing ecosystem of
undersea nightmares both fit this
category nicely as was the case with
rain world I've already covered these
virtual ecosystems in detail but if you
want to feel like a very minute part of
a large food chain they would be among
my top recommendations it's also worth
noting that as you progress through both
Minecraft and Zelda you might start to
feel less and less beholden to the food
chain as your abilities grow indeed
there's an argument to be made that
you're not really part of these
ecosystems but conquering them it's a
feeling that can arise as you near the
end of a lot of open world titles but
even in the late stages of Minecraft and
Zelda there's no way to fully disconnect
from the world around you no matter your
experience level you can pretty much
always be caught off guard by something
in the environment as games with a
significant amount of player Freedom how
much you disrupt the digital ecosystems
of Minecraft and Zelda is ultimately up
to you in the end the option to keep the
land around you green and unspoiled is
always available
Life In an undamaged ecosystem is not an
option in the game endling endling
didn't begin the way I expected based on
screenshots I thought it was a
relatively innocent game about a family
of foxes but when I booted it up I was
greeted by these two dark shapes
floating against a red background the
camera pulled out and I realized those
were embryos in a mother Fox's womb and
the world outside was on fire almost
immediately I found myself inhabiting
the perspective of the mother Fox I
controlled reduced to the single
Instinct of moving forwards a burning
deer sent me hurtling off a ledge still
I pressed onwards limping through the
smoke in the rain at last I made it to
shelter and as a scene played of the
mother having her Cubs I took what felt
like my first breath since pressing
start but the scene wasn't over because
then the camera panned up out of the den
to remind me what kind of a world these
Cubs had been brought into
endling is a game that traps you within
its setting ingeniously from here the
gameplay changes into a stressful cycle
of finding food for your Cubs before the
night ends to reflect this new format
the Raging Inferno is replaced with
desolate snowfall tracking down food in
this Barren ecosystem is a constant
Challenge and to make things more
challenging before long your Cubs start
coming with you to learn how to hunt
trying to remain alive while also
protecting your pups requires constant
vigilance pulling you further into the
world though technically
post-apocalyptic endling depicts a
future much closer in time than most
works of sci-fi one ravaged by the
mistakes of humanity as a game rooted in
the perspective of a fox no dialogue
communicates its themes of environmental
degradation instead the devastation is
felt in the bareness of the ecosystem
itself in the decaying remnants that
make up the landscape humans themselves
are rare their gas mask making them feel
alien in helping you think of them as
threats the same way the fox does to
drag you further into the psyche of an
animal one of your Cubs is carried off
early in the game by a human Survivor
but though the game teaches you that the
world of humanity is best avoided as
food becomes scarce you find yourself
taking greater and greater risks just to
keep your Cubs alive this all came to a
head for me when one night starving from
lack of things to hunt I allowed my Cubs
to feed on noxious looking garbage not
knowing if it was toxic it's a moment
that wouldn't be nearly as powerful if I
hadn't been forced to make that choice
myself due to the ecosystem scarcity
the later stages of Gibbon use in-game
systems to convey ecological Devastation
in a similar manner after a while you
start seeing plumes of smoke in
clear-cut groves in the background
swinging itself begins to feel different
as the number of trees decline
eventually a full-scale fire breaks out
sending the forest ecosystem into a
panic missing a branch holds new weight
is falling into the forest below now
means succumbing to The Inferno Crossing
large gaps are now key for survival
turning what was once a joyous
expression of Freedom into a grim
necessity even later the natural forests
give way to rows of monoculture crops
that are difficult to swing through
which then transition into urban areas
here again Gibbon doesn't need dialogue
to convey its themes the simple
mechanical awkwardness of trying to
navigate rooftops instead of the
branches you're accustomed to says more
than a direct statement on environmental
destruction potentially could have
maybe it should be no surprise that
games that make you part of an ecosystem
can get you to think more about the
world around you after all humans are
already part of an ecosystem even if it
doesn't always feel that way in our
daily lives though we are a relatively
insignificant part of Earth's history on
a cosmic scale we have the capacity to
profoundly influence our environment in
the present and after playing through
some of these games I can't help but
wonder what kind of ending we're headed
towards
if there's an ecosystem focused game
with a more hopeful if Bittersweet
conclusion I'd say it's probably planet
of Lana it's a game that exposes you to
constant imagery of the mechanical
interrupting the natural world and yet
it's also very much a story about how
you can learn from the mistakes of the
past to create a better tomorrow as you
progress through the game educating
yourself on the ins and outs of the
environment you gain a tremendous
appreciation for the world around you
all without a single sentence of
dialogue spoken and while I won't spoil
the final moments I will say the ending
stayed with me long after the credits
rolled
ultimately there's no single way to
create an effective ecosystem based game
across many different genres and art
styles game studios have made a
startling variety of Worlds ruled by
interactive systems and there's plenty
of games with unique fictional
ecosystems that I wasn't able to cover
here if you're interested in Virtual
ecosystems I've got the full list of
games featured in this video down below
and as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video